الامام الاهالي تحديدا سوى الامل خصوصا
بعد مرور خمسه ايام واكثر من 120 ساعه
ويعني على اعتاب اليوم السادس يتمسك
الاهالي بالامل مع الانباء التي ترد سواء
من كهرمان مرعش او المناطق الاخرى بان
هناك ناجين يخرجون حتى هذه اللحظه ولذلك
يبقوا متمسكين بهذا الامل حتى اللحظه
الاخيره يعني في مناطق المنكوبه والدمار
الذي حل بالبلاد في جنوب البلاد هنا هناك
يعني احد الزملاء يشير لي بان هناك خمس
جثث في هذه هذا المبنى الذي يقع خلفي حنين
في الامس كانوا يتحدثون عن
العمل جاري حنين على انتشالهم كما تشاهدين
الان ستلاحظين بالصوره العمل جاري على
انتشالهم للاسف بالامس كان عناصر الانقاذ
ابلغونا بان هذا المبنى فيه خمس اشخاص على
قيد الحياه
واليوم نتحدث عن خمس جثث وبالتالي هو ما
كنت تشير له قبل قليل حنين بان هناك معدل
زمني للعالقين تحت الانقاذ ثلاثه ايام
الاولى وبعد ذلك تقل وتتضائل نسب النجاح
فكنا نتحدث عن خمسه هنا اليوم يقولون انهم
ماتوا وباتوا جثث ويحاولون انتشال هذه
الجثث ايضا في مبنى مقابل لهذا المبنى كان
هناك ثلاثه اشخاص
ونفس الشيء ذات الشيء فقدوا الامل بهم
ويبدو انه لا يوجد اي اشارات على انهم على
قيد الحياه وايضا انتشلوا جثه اخرى من
مبنى اخر يعني
في الساعات الاخيره في الثلاث ساعات
الاخيره تم انتشار الاربعه جثث وما زال
العمل جاري في جميع المباني حنين نعود
لموضوع الامل حنين كما قلت لك لكن عناصر
الانقاذ تواصل هذا العمل الاهالي
المتمسكين بالامل فرق الانقاذ تعمل ليلا
نهارا على مدار الساعه خليه نحل نحن نقف
في شارع في عشرات المنازل حنين مدمره
بالكامل يعني نستطيع القول بانه احياء
مدمره بالكامل